Jake: 今天是谷雨
Jake: Today is Grain Rain.
Shure:  今天还是个节气呢
Shure: Today is a solar term.
Shure:  是个节气吃什么
Shure: What do we eat for a solar term?
Shure:  吃饺子吧
Shure: Let's eat dumplings.
Lucia: 哈哈哈遇事不决吃饺子
Lucia: Hahaha, when in doubt, eat dumplings.
Shure:  对啊反正咱也不知道吃什么
Shure: Yeah, we don't know what to eat anyway.
Jake: 摘谷雨茶走
Jake: Let's pick some Guyu tea.
Jake: 谷雨祭海
Jake: Guyu sea festival.
Jake: 吃春赏花
Jake: Eat in spring and enjoy flowers.
Jake: 什么玩意
Jake: What nonsense.
Lucia: 不知道在赏花
Lucia: No idea, looking at flowers.
Lucia: 咱可以有
Lucia: We can have that.
Shure:  那就吃饺子吧
Shure: Then let's eat dumplings.
Jake: 吃饺子行
Jake: Dumplings are fine.
Jake: 可以啊中午吃饺子吧
Jake: Sure, let's have dumplings for lunch.
Jake: 要不行
Jake: How about it?
Jake: 妙啊
Jake: Brilliant.
Lucia: 哎遇事不好
Lucia: Hey, things aren't going well.
Lucia: 咱这有铅笔吗
Lucia: Do we have pencils?
Jake: 没有铅笔哦
Jake: No pencils, sorry.
Shure:  昨天昨天晚上怎么偷偷发红包呢
Shure: Why did you secretly send red envelopes last night?
Jake: 那就发工资
Jake: Then let's pay the salary.
Tasha: 我四肢手臂也太细了吧
Tasha: My arms are too skinny.
Jake: 哎工资还没发完呢
Jake: Hey, the salary isn't fully paid yet.
Tasha: 到底是谁在说他
Tasha: Who is talking about him?
Lucia: 突然来真的
Lucia: Suddenly serious.
Jake: what are you doing
Jake: What are you doing?
Jake: 干啥呢
Tasha: 我感觉大家没有干什么
Tasha: I feel like everyone is doing nothing.
Jake:确实没干什么嗯
Jake: Indeed, doing nothing.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake: 收拾收拾
Jake: Let's tidy up.
Jake: 呃你装饰房间
Jake: Uh, you decorate the room.
Tasha: 好好
Tasha: Okay, sure.
Tasha: 好对
Tasha: Yeah, right.
Jake:然后一块玩狗去
Jake: And then let's play with the dog.
Jake:快递来了
Jake: The package is here.
Jake:你好拆对吧
Jake: You can open it, right?
Tasha: 好来了吗
Tasha: Sure, has it arrived?
Jake:还没有等来了去拆快递
Jake: Not yet, wait until it arrives to open it.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake: 然后今天是谷雨
Jake: And today is Guyu.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake: 谷雨要干什么呀
Jake: What should we do for Guyu?
Tasha: 谷雨
Tasha: Grain Rain
Jake:一个节气
Jake: It's a solar term.
Tasha: 我知道哈哈
Tasha: I know, haha.
Tasha: 你搜一搜嘛
Tasha: Why don't you look it up?
Jake: 好搜一搜
Jake: Okay, I'll look it up.
Jake: 问问GPT吧
Jake: Let's ask GPT.
Tasha: 谷雨节气习俗要赏牡丹走谷雨
Tasha: The customs of the Grain Rain solar term include admiring peonies and walking in the rain.
Tasha: 吃三色饭
Tasha: Eating three-colored rice.
Jake: 三色饭
Jake: Three-colored rice?
Tasha: 嗯应该弄糙米饭吧
Tasha: 吃香菜我不过这个节日
Tasha: Eat cilantro, but I don't celebrate this holiday.
Jake: 那就点个餐盒饭吧
Jake: Then let's just order a meal box.
Tasha: 这谁的包你要不要坐个垫
Tasha: Whose bag is this? Do you want to use it as a cushion?
Jake: 我可以不坐留给你坐
Jake: I can stand, you can sit.
Jake:啊这就是三色饭
Jake: Ah, so this is three-colored rice.
Tasha: 哈哈好
Tasha: Haha, okay.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 什么叫三色饭
Jake: What is three-colored rice?
Tasha: 我觉得应该就是白米红米和黑米吧
Tasha: I think it's probably white rice, red rice, and black rice.
Tasha: 或问集体
Tasha: Or ask the group.
Tasha: 你帮我戒戒烟好吗
Tasha: Can you help me quit smoking?
Jake:呃今天是谷雨
Jake: Uh, today is Grain Rain.
Jake:谷雨这个节气一般吃什么呢
Jake: What do people usually eat during the Grain Rain solar term?
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
Tasha: 唱的还挺好听的
Tasha: This singing is pretty good.
Tasha: 这是不是放的
Tasha: Is this a recording?
Jake: 看看瞅瞅去
Jake: Let's go take a look.
Shure: 下棋吗
Shure: Want to play chess?
Alice: 可以呀
Alice: Sure.
Shure: 来下棋
Shure: Let's play chess.
其他人:放这可以吗
Others: Can we put this here?
Shure:  成成
Shure: Okay, sure.
Jake: 要不放二楼去
Jake: Or put it on the second floor.
Jake: 放二楼拆吧
Jake: Unpack it on the second floor.
Jake: 位置大一点放二楼桌上拆吧
Jake: There's more space there. Put it on the table on the second floor.
Lucia: 要不好一楼用的东西在一楼拆
Lucia: Or maybe unpack the things for the first floor on the first floor.
Lucia: 二楼用的东西在二楼拆
Lucia: And the things for the second floor on the second floor.
Lucia: 要不然话都搬上去
Lucia: Otherwise, we have to move everything upstairs.
Lucia: 然后再搬下来对吧
Lucia: And then move it back down, right?
Lucia: 大家可以认领一下自己的快递
Lucia: Everyone can claim their own packages.
Jake: 来来来认领一下吧
Jake: Come on, come on, claim your stuff.
Lucia: 剩下都得明天才能到好嘞
Lucia: The rest will only arrive tomorrow, okay?
Lucia: 我想给你看那个小夜灯
Lucia: I want to show you the little night light.
Lucia: 他真的很可爱
Lucia: It's really cute.
Lucia: 是我特别喜欢玩的一个
Lucia: It's one of my favorite little toys.
Lucia: 以前特别喜欢玩的一个小游戏
Lucia: It used to be one of my favorite little games.
Tasha: 杨
Tasha: Jake.
Tasha: 杨就是他的呗
Tasha: Jake, it's his, right?
Tasha: 他买了绿晶石精油
Tasha: He bought green crystal essential oil.
Tasha: 哦不好意思
Tasha: Oh, sorry.
Katrina:  没事没事
Katrina: It's okay, it's okay.
Tasha: 我的在哪里
Tasha: Where's mine?
Lucia: 这个可能是杨老师
Lucia: This might be Jake's.
Shure:  你看看你看
Shure: Look, look.
Shure:  原来我私人iPad从来不会给我推
Shure: My personal iPad never pushes this kind of thing to me.
Shure:  这种华语大流行你知道吗
Shure: This kind of Mandarin pop, you know?
Lucia: 这个应该也是到了好久了对
Lucia: This should have arrived a long time ago, right?
Tasha: 好久了
Tasha: A long time ago.
Tasha: 哦把这个拆了
Tasha: Oh, let's unwrap this.
Lucia: 卖贴纸的小女孩
Lucia: The little girl who sells stickers.
Tasha: 剪刀嘞
Tasha: Scissors?
Tasha: 也没有小刀呀
Tasha: There's no small knife either.
Tasha: 我的快递呢
Tasha: Where's my package?
Tasha: 就这些吗不对呀
Tasha: Is this all? No way.
Jake: 你快递有单号的话你可以群里面问他
Jake: If your package has a tracking number, you can ask in the group.
Tasha: 快递就这些吗
Tasha: Is this all the packages?
Lucia: 有的可能
Lucia: Maybe some are...
Lucia: 是不是还没到
Lucia: Not here yet?
Tasha: 我的到了呀
Tasha: Mine arrived, though.
Tasha: 他没有帮我拿
Tasha: He didn't bring it for me.
Jake: 那你就在群里面干他
Jake: Then just nag him in the group.
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Sigh.
Lucia: battle一下对
Lucia: Battle it out, right?
Tasha: 没有啊
Tasha: No, no.
Alice: 我的调很准
Alice: My tone is very accurate.
Alice: 但是如果说就是专有的一些
Alice: But if we're talking about specific...
Alice: 那啥
Alice: You know what I mean.
Lucia: 那已经很厉害了我根本
Lucia: That's already very impressive, I simply...
Alice: 这个很难界定吧
Alice: This is hard to define, right?
Lucia: 哦好像陕北口音会差别大一点
Lucia: Oh, it seems the Shaanxi accent might be more different.
Tasha: 能帮我一下吗
Tasha: Can you help me?
Tasha: 拿到外面晒一下
Tasha: Take it outside to dry.
Tasha: 感觉有点味道
Tasha: It kind of smells.
Jake: 这就是我们要摆甜品的东西
Jake: This is what we will use to display the desserts.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 是有点味道
Tasha: It does smell a bit.
Jake: 今天没太阳
Jake: There's no sun today.
Tasha: 饺子
Tasha: Dumplings.
Jake: 还有那个香椿饼
Jake: And that toona pancake.
Tasha: 谁
Tasha: Who?
Lucia: 椿饼
Lucia: Toona pancake.
Jake: 香椿饼哎
Jake: Yeah, toona pancake.
Lucia: 可以我喜欢香椿香椿
Lucia: Sure, I like toona, toona.
Tasha: 香椿香椿是什么
Tasha: What's toona?
Alice: 今天是谷雨
Alice: Today is Grain Rain.
Alice: 是今天确实应该吃香椿
Alice: Yes, today we should eat toona.
Tasha: 香椿是什么
Tasha: What's toona?
Alice: 香椿是一种
Alice: Toona is a kind of...
Jake: 你肯定知道因为我们加了一个荠菜
Jake: You must know because we added shepherd's purse.
Tasha: 荠菜
Tasha: Shepherd's purse?
Tasha: 是荠菜吗
Tasha: Is it shepherd's purse?
Alice: 不是荠菜
Alice: No, it's not shepherd's purse.
Jake: 荠就差不多的东西吧
Jake: It's something similar to shepherd's purse, I guess.
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake: 放文件呢
Jake: Put the files here.
Jake: 放笔筒笔筒
Jake: And the pen holder.
Jake: 放文件袋
Jake: And the file folder.
Jake: 文件夹
Jake: The binder.
Tasha: 太好了做完我就带回去放文件夹
Tasha: Great, once it's done, I'll take it back to hold files.
Tasha: 呵呵
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 我可以申请瓜分一个吗带回去
Lucia: Can I apply to split one and take it back?
Tasha: 你想瓜分哪个
Tasha: Which one do you want to split?
Lucia: 可能这个吧
Lucia: Maybe this one.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Sure.
Jake: 对这能放记事本
Jake: Yeah, this can hold a notebook.
Lucia: 底下可以放点小东西
Lucia: The bottom can hold some small stuff.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Lucia: 然后上面上面可以放我买那个小夜灯
Lucia: And the top can hold that small night light I bought.
Lucia: 我打算把那个夜灯给他带回家去
Lucia: I'm planning to take that night light home.
Tasha: 这个这个怎么弄啊
Tasha: How do you do this one?
Jake: 这是啥呀
Jake: What is this?
Alice: 应该有螺丝可以把那个钉拧上去哦
Alice: There should be screws to fix that nail in place.
Jake: 哎哦这个确实哦
Jake: Oh, indeed, there are.
Lucia: 那您那个您那个
Lucia: So, you mean that...
Tasha: 哦那那个
Tasha: Oh, that...
Lucia: 那个小螺丝刀可以
Lucia: That little screwdriver should work.
Tasha: 他没有给
Tasha: He didn't give it.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Lucia: 没事杨老板好多螺丝刀
Lucia: No worries, Jake has plenty of screwdrivers.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 放这吧就一个
Jake: Just put it here, just one.
Jake: 哈哈哈啊啊啊
Jake: Hahaha, ah ah ah.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Tasha: 啊啊
Tasha: Ah ah.
Tasha: 不是还有一个吗
Tasha: Isn't there another one?
Jake: 这里面还有两个好像
Jake: There seem to be two more in here.
Jake: 希望没有
Jake: Hopefully not.
Tasha: 这还有一个够了吗
Tasha: There's another one here, is it enough?
Jake: 不够
Jake: Not enough.
Tasha: 啊要几个
Tasha: Ah, how many do we need?
Jake: 四个
Jake: Four.
Tasha: 这不是3个吗
Tasha: Isn't this three?
Tasha: 这上面还有一个
Tasha: There's one more on top.
Jake: 对不起
Jake: Sorry.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Alright then.
Lucia: 这就是单独的吗
Lucia: Is this one separate?
Tasha: 嗯好像是
Tasha: Hmm, seems like it.
Tasha: 我也不知道就这样
Tasha: I don't know, just like this.
Jake: 今天晒不了太阳
Jake: Can't get any sun today.
Jake: 有点亏亏的
Jake: A bit of a loss.
Tasha: 挺好看
Tasha: Looks pretty good.
Lucia: 哈哈今天可以去春游
Lucia: Haha, we can go for a spring outing today.
Tasha: 他们说今天不春游
Tasha: They said no spring outing today.
Alice: 今天应该就在家里蹲
Alice: We should probably just stay at home today.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 菲利菲尔
Lucia: Phillifil.
Lucia:游
Alice: 这咋啦烫的还是
Alice: What's wrong, is it burnt or...
Tasha: 烫了吧应该
Tasha: It's probably burnt.
Tasha: 以前烫的对
Tasha: It was burnt before, right?
Tasha: 已经不记得了
Tasha: I already don't remember.
Lucia: 哎你画了一个项链
Lucia: Hey, you drew a necklace.
Alice: 是的跟他的衣服配套的
Alice: Yeah, it matches his clothes.
Alice: 嗯超可爱的
Alice: Hmm, super cute.
Alice: 小心思小妙小妙思
Alice: Just a little thought, a little ingenious thought.
Lucia: 好多巴胺
Lucia: So much dopamine.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 女孩
Lucia: Girl.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 明显吗
Tasha: Is it obvious?
Alice: 啥
Alice: What?
Tasha: 哦我还以为
Tasha: Oh, I thought...
Alice:是那个头发
Alice: It's the hair.
Tasha: 还以为是内衣带
Tasha: I thought it was a bra strap.
Tasha: 太明显了
Tasha: It's too obvious.
Alice: 这有什么的没事
Alice: It's nothing, don't worry about it.
Alice: 坐下吹会风吗
Alice: Want to sit down and catch some breeze?
Alice: 饿吗
Alice: Hungry?
Tasha: 不饿
Tasha: Not hungry.
Jake: 这是我22年年底在
Jake: This was me at the end of '22...
Tasha: 哦小米是吗
Tasha: Oh, is that Xiaomi?
Lucia: 这是你那个超高级的起子吗
Jake:不是小米
Jake: No, it's not Xiaomi.
Jake:我也不知道是什么玩意
Jake: I don't even know what it is.
Jake: 就就是
Jake: It's just...
Tasha: 小米也有
Tasha: Xiaomi has it too.
Jake: 嗯挺多的这种
Jake: Yeah, there's a lot like this.
Jake: 嗯那年隔离回国
Jake: That year, I was quarantined after returning to the country.
Jake: 隔离在酒店
Jake: Quarantined in a hotel.
Tasha: 这是干嘛的
Tasha: What's this for?
Tasha: 这是不同的头吗
Tasha: Are these different heads?
Jake: 对拆电脑的
Jake: Yeah, for dismantling computers.
Jake: 当时把我麦克给拆了
Jake: Back then, I dismantled my mic.
Jake: 然后拆了没装回去
Jake: And then didn't put it back together.
Jake: 哈哈哈最后变成个台式机
Jake: Haha, it ended up becoming a desktop.
Jake: 啊哈哈哈
Jake: Ahahaha.
Jake: 惊慌散了
Jake: Panic spread.
Jake: 你知道散装了
Jake: You know, it was all scattered.
Jake: 哦行吧
Jake: Oh, okay.
Lucia: 哦行吧
Lucia: 散装但依然能用
Lucia: Disassembled but still usable.
Jake: 散装能用
Jake: Disassembled but usable.
Lucia: 这这怎么不算一种赛博朋克呢
Lucia: Isn't this kind of cyberpunk?
Jake:太赛博了
Jake: So cyberpunk.
Lucia: 哇行吧
Lucia: Wow, alright.
Tasha: 这个就是不同的头都有
Tasha: This one has all different heads.
Lucia: 我修我修过
Lucia: I fixed it.
Lucia: 我修电脑干过最大的工程
Lucia: The biggest project I've done.
Lucia: 就是给自己加装内存条
Lucia: Was installing RAM for myself.
Lucia: 剩下我啥都不敢干
Lucia: Other than that, I don't dare touch anything.
Lucia: 因为我要是拆了我就装不回去了
Lucia: Because if I take it apart, I can't put it back together.
Jake: 当时为了换了几个键盘键
Jake: I once replaced a few keyboard keys.
Jake: 然后把整个麦克给拆了
Jake: Ended up disassembling the whole mic.
Lucia: 但是您把它拆了还得组装成台式机
Lucia: But you still had to reassemble it into a desktop.
Lucia: 这我真没想到
Lucia: That I didn't expect.
Lucia: 怎么凭空还多了一些零件呢
Lucia: How did we end up with extra parts out of nowhere?
Jake: 没有就是屏幕散开
Jake: No, it was just the screen coming apart.
Lucia: 就是装回去发现零件多了
Lucia: I mean, we put it back together and had extra parts.
Tasha: 是不是应该先
Tasha: Should we...
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 这确实
Jake: That's true.
Alice: 香椿饼是你点的吗
Alice: Did you order the Toona pancakes?
Shure:  不是
Shure: No.
Alice:不是吗
Alice: No?
Jake: 呃算是呃
Jake: Uh, sort of, uh...
Jake: 百度文信一年都没开
Jake: I haven't opened Baidu Wenxin for a year.
Shure:  他问百度的
Shure: He asked Baidu.
Jake: 对只能问百度
Jake: Yeah, I had to ask Baidu.
Shure:  这谷雨要吃啥
Shure: What should we eat for Grain Rain?
Tasha: 香椿饼
Tasha: Toona pancakes.
Jake: 对他没说饺子
Jake: Yeah, he didn't say dumplings.
Jake: 但是我们还是点
Jake: But we ordered them anyway.
Shure:  因为饺子总不会错的
Shure: Because dumplings never go wrong.
Shure:  毕竟好吃不过饺子
Shure: After all, nothing beats dumplings.
Alice: 我还以为香椿饼是专门点的
Alice: I thought the Toona pancakes were specially ordered.
Jake: 就是是是专门点的就是
Jake: Yeah, they were, they were ordered specifically.
Shure:  为了今天这个节气
Shure: For today's solar term.
Tasha: 杨老板
Tasha: Jake.
Jake: 对问了百度说今儿应该吃点啥
Jake: Yes, asked Baidu what we should eat today.
Jake: 今天还有叫逛古语还是走
Jake: 谷雨什么呀
Jake: 走谷雨
Shure:  就是拿着篮子出去溜达一圈
Tasha: 那我要拿着
Katrina:  那我们去撸狗吧
Tasha: 那我们去撸狗吧
Shure:  对我们就拿着个
Jake: 对对对对对对
Jake: 是啥呀
Tasha: 哦
Shure:  然后唱着采蘑菇的小姑娘哈哈
Lucia: 我特别喜欢这个颜色哦
Tasha: 哦
Lucia: 感觉很好看
Jake: 我要把它给先拿出来
Tasha: 写的什么乱七八糟的
Lucia: 希拉维
Tasha: 是吧这什么语
Lucia: 法语哦
Tasha: 对不起
Lucia: 但这个c这是不是写错了
Lucia: But isn't this 'c' written wrong?
Lucia: 应该是CES
Lucia: It should be CES.
Lucia: 是哪个我法语不好
Jake:马丽知道生活
Jake: Marie knows life.
Jake:别的不认
Jake: She doesn't recognize anything else.
Lucia: 希拉维就是指好像这就是生活
Lucia: C'est la vie, it means "that's life."
Lucia: no是我们
Lucia: No, it's us.
Jake:ok
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 我们的组合
Lucia: It's our group.
Lucia: 如果只有一个日的话
Lucia: If there's only one '日' character,
Lucia: 就是就是白天或者今天的意思
Lucia: it means either 'daytime' or 'today.'
Alice: 法语是表音的文字吗
Alice: Is French a phonetic language?
Lucia: 是啊
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 呃不是吗
Lucia: Uh, isn't it?
Lucia: 不是你是语言学的吗
Alice: 不是不是我不是我
Alice: No, no, not me, not me.
Alice: 我没我不知道啊
Alice: I don't know.
Lucia: 应该是吧
Lucia: It should be.
Lucia: 像他们这些拉丁语系的
Lucia: Like those Romance languages,
Lucia: 应该都是表音的
Lucia: they should all be phonetic.
Lucia: 看不太懂
Lucia: I can't really understand.
Jake: 应该都就中文
Jake: It should all be in Chinese.
Jake: 还有谁
Jake: Who else?
Lucia: 个不知道啊
Lucia: I don't know.
Lucia: 东亚地区就这些语言
Lucia: These are the languages in East Asia.
Tasha: 哎就是这个另一个那个呢
Tasha: Oh, there's this other one.
Tasha: 螺丝呢
Tasha: Where's the screw?
Jake:  在这呢放回去
Jake: It's here, put it back.
Tasha: 这人也太抠了
Tasha: This person is so stingy.
Tasha: 就发四个螺丝
Tasha: Only four screws.
Tasha: 要是丢了怎么办
Tasha: What if we lose one?
Jake: 给我粘上
Jake: Stick it on.
Jake: 我们有很多双双面胶
Jake: We've got plenty of double-sided tape.
Jake: 摄像头的双面胶
Jake: Double-sided tape for the camera.
Jake: 都很给力都很猛
Jake: It's really strong.
Lucia: 哇真猛啊
Lucia: Wow, really strong.
Lucia: 你看过罗翔的那个刑法视频
Lucia: Have you seen Luo Xiang's criminal law videos?
Jake: 看过
Jake: Yeah, I've seen them.
Lucia: 警察局局长从旁边过
Lucia: The police chief walked by.
Lucia: 说好猛啊
Lucia: He said it's awesome.
Tasha: 不是这个
Tasha: Not this one.
Tasha: 哦是这
Tasha: Oh, it's this one.
Jake:好猛啊
Jake: So awesome.
Lucia: 看不懂
Lucia: I don't understand.
Tasha: 看不懂
Tasha: I don't understand.
Lucia:我法语基本上是看剧学的
Lucia: I basically learned French from watching shows.
Lucia:所以就是一旦不是台词我就看不懂
Lucia: So if it's not a script, I don't understand.
Jake: 要不翻译一下就是
Jake: How about translating it?
Jake:就是拿手机翻译一下啊
Jake: Just use your phone to translate.
Lucia: 但谷歌翻译在国内用不上
Lucia: But Google Translate doesn't work here.
Lucia: 哦我现在有那个啥
Lucia: Oh, now I have...
Jake: 你现在有了
Jake: You have it now?
Lucia: 对现在呵呵呵
Lucia: Yes, now, haha.
Jake: 现在不是
Jake: 就在这个墙外墙外墙内不是一个体系
Jake: Inside the wall and outside the wall, it's not the same system.
Lucia: 这个比较容易看懂
Lucia: This is easier to understand.
Lucia:但我觉得
Lucia: But I think...
Lucia:这个咖啡和巴西的拼写
Lucia: The spelling of coffee and Brazil...
Lucia: 是不是不太对啊
Lucia: Isn't it a bit off?
Lucia: 100%阿拉提卡咖啡
Lucia: 100% Arabica coffee.
Tasha: 啊哪里有咖啡我是说盒子上应该印
Tasha: Ah, where's the coffee? I mean, it should be printed on the box.
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: It's fine.
Lucia: 我们可以假装咖啡豆
Lucia: We can pretend they are coffee beans.
Jake: 咖啡豆
Jake: Coffee beans?
Jake: 咖啡豆是吧
Jake: Coffee beans, right?
Jake: 我知道这个是英语
Jake: I know this is in English.
Jake: 纯英语这个是什么
Jake: Pure English, what is this?
Jake: 这是哪
Jake: Where is this?
Tasha: OK
Tasha: OK.
Jake: 国语西语
Jake: National language, Spanish?
Lucia: 不是吧我不知道
Lucia: No way, I don't know.
Tasha: 你说这盒子里能放什么好吃的吗
Tasha: Do you think we can put something delicious in this box?
Tasha: 这不开玩笑嘛
Tasha: Isn't this a joke?
Jake: 这个还得晒晒对吧
Jake: This still needs to be dried, right?
Jake: 吹一吹吧
Jake: Let's blow it dry.
Tasha: 我就把这两盒子拿走
Tasha: I'll just take these two boxes away.
Tasha: 这样的放还比较好放
Tasha: It's easier to place them like this.
Jake: 那我刚刚干嘛了
Jake: What was I doing just now?
Lucia: 这个可以放在旁边当装饰啊
Lucia: This can be placed on the side as a decoration.
Jake: 也行吧
Jake: That works too.
Tasha: 这个可以单独的
Tasha: This can be separate.
Tasha: 这样子啊
Tasha: Like this, huh?
Jake: 对对对对对
Jake: Right, right, right.
Jake: 看来我们东西有很多啊
Jake: Looks like we have a lot of stuff.
Jake: 很多很多
Jake: A lot, a lot.
Alice: 这个适合放口红
Alice: This is suitable for holding lipsticks.
Alice: 还带分装格
Alice: It even has compartments.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mm-hmm.
Lucia: 这个放进去可以放那个什么放什么
Lucia: You can put those small things like earrings and studs in here.
Lucia: 耳环耳钉这种小首饰
Lucia: Like small jewelry.
Tasha: 好好太好了
Tasha: Great, that's awesome.
Lucia: 特别棒首饰盒放桌子上还不占地方
Lucia: It's a wonderful jewelry box, and it doesn't take up space on the table.
Lucia: 我们已经给他想好
Lucia: We've already planned it out.
Tasha: 就是以后就这么归宿了
Tasha: So this will be its final place from now on.
Lucia: 这个呢
Lucia: What about this?
Tasha: 装可爱
Tasha: Cute display.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake: 这怎么装可爱
Jake: How is this cute?
Jake: 这什么玩意
Jake: What is this thing?
Lucia: 他比较可爱
Lucia: It's kind of cute.
Jake: 小房子是吧
Jake: A small house, right?
Lucia: 像那种爆钟的那种
Lucia: Like those exploding clocks.
Jake:装可爱
Jake: Acting cute.
Alice: 他可以勾住勾住好像
Alice: It can hook, I think.
Tasha: 他可以勾
Tasha: It can hook.
Lucia: 对是的给里面放个放个圆
Lucia: Yes, put a circle inside.
Tasha: 对是的
Tasha: Yes, that's right.
Lucia: 那个啥墙时钟
Lucia: That wall clock.
Lucia: 然后在上面再放一个小鸟
Lucia: And then put a little bird on top.
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Lucia: 好这个的日后归宿也想好了
Lucia: Okay, I've thought about its future.
Lucia: 那俩盘不用给他想什么
Lucia: You don't need to think too much about those two plates.
Lucia: 因为都挺都很常见很好用
Lucia: Because they're common and very useful.
Alice: 这个是不是也能可以养小蜘蛛
Alice: Can this also be used to raise little spiders?
Alice: 一人一个隔间
Alice: Each one in a separate compartment.
Lucia: 太小了
Lucia: Too small.
Jake:会爬出来
Jake: They'll crawl out.
Lucia: 对狼猪会爬出来
Lucia: Yeah, wolf spiders will crawl out.
Alice: 就是我想养蛇
Alice: Actually, I want to raise snakes.
Lucia: 我也想养蛇
Lucia: I want to raise snakes too.
Alice: 喜欢两栖动物
Lucia: 对我也想养蛇
Lucia: Yeah, I also want to raise snakes.
Lucia: 但是我
Lucia: But I...
Tasha: 之前我还有一个学长
Tasha: I had a senior before...
Tasha: 他养那个什么守宫啊
Tasha: He raised geckos or something.
Alice: 啊蜥蜴
Alice: Oh, lizards.
Tasha: 然后每天他的手上就爬着一条蛇
Tasha: And he always had a snake crawling on his hand.
Tasha: 肩上还爬着一条
Tasha: And another one crawling on his shoulder.
Tasha: 有点吓人
Tasha: It was a bit scary.
Lucia: 我也想养蛇
Lucia: I also want to raise snakes.
Jake: 狼珠多大呀
Jake: How big do wolf spiders get?
Lucia: 就看你买的多大
Lucia: Depends on what size you buy.
Lucia: 也可以你也可以从这么小开始养
Lucia: You can start with a small one.
Lucia: 你也可以直接买一个拳头大的
Lucia: Or you can buy one as big as a fist.
Lucia: 对他会蜕皮然后慢慢变得很大
Lucia: They shed their skin and slowly grow bigger.
Jake: 它最大能到哪
Jake: How big can they get?
Lucia: 最大一般可能超不过大巴掌这么大吧
Lucia: Generally, they don't get bigger than a large palm.
Lucia: 我感觉
Lucia: I think.
Lucia: 因为直接买拳头那么大的
Lucia: Because if you buy one as big as a fist...
Lucia: 因为从这么小开始养
Lucia: And start raising it from a small size...
Lucia: 很容易中间把它养死
Lucia: It's easy to accidentally kill it in the middle.
Jake: 他营养不够高血
Jake: It's not getting enough nutrition.
Lucia: 呃不知道为啥就是
Lucia: Uh, I don't know why, it's just...
Jake: 好吧不知道要养几年
Jake: Okay, I don't know how many years it needs to be raised.
Jake: 这个他能活多久
Jake: How long can it live?
Lucia: 能活多久
Lucia: How long can it live?
Lucia: 我也不知道
Lucia: I don't know either.
Lucia: 我经常把
Lucia: I often...
Jake: 真不知道
Jake: Really don't know.
Lucia: 能活能活多久啊
Lucia: How long can it live?
Lucia: 两三年应该不清楚
Lucia: Two or three years maybe, not sure.
Alice: 想养蛇
Alice: I want to raise a snake.
Lucia: 我也想养蛇
Lucia: I want to raise a snake too.
Lucia: 但是蛇要吃老鼠崽子
Lucia: But snakes need to eat baby mice.
Lucia: 对然后那个东西要放冰箱冷藏
Lucia: Yeah, and you have to store those in the fridge.
Lucia: 我不是很能接受
Lucia: I can't really accept that.
Lucia: 他跟我冰箱
Lucia: Sharing the fridge with me.
Lucia: 他跟我共用一个冰箱放吃的
Lucia: Sharing the same fridge for food.
Alice: 你可以专门给他买个冰箱
Alice: You could buy a separate fridge for it.
Jake: 买什么老鼠崽子
Jake: Buy baby mice?
Lucia: 舍不得哈哈哈
Lucia: I can't bear to, haha.
Lucia: 太贵了比蛇都贵
Lucia: Too expensive, more than the snake.
Jake: 老鼠崽子是什么
Jake: What are baby mice?
Lucia: 就老鼠崽子
Lucia: Just baby mice.
Lucia: 那刚出生的老鼠崽子
Lucia: Newly born baby mice.
Jake: 哦然后为什么冻起来
Jake: Oh, why do they need to be frozen?
Lucia: 因为要给蛇吃
Lucia: Because they're for the snake to eat.
Lucia: 就是你不能让它吃的毒死了吧
Lucia: You can't let it eat something poisonous, right?
Jake: 他他是活的吗
Jake: Are they alive?
Lucia: 不是就是应该是新鲜的死老鼠
Lucia: No, they should be freshly dead mice.
Jake: 为什么能不能
Jake: Why not...
Jake: 能不能养点活的
Jake: Why not raise some live ones?
Tasha: 我以后要死老鼠就在大城市开始捕鼠
Tasha: If I need dead mice, I'll start catching them in big cities.
Lucia: 养活老鼠
Lucia: Raise live mice.
Alice: 然后卖哦
Alice: Then sell them.
Tasha: 然后卖
Tasha: Then sell them.
Jake: 刚死的活老鼠
Jake: Freshly dead live mice.
Lucia: 他一般就是
Lucia: Usually...
Lucia: 就是那种爬虫店就会有卖
Lucia: Pet stores that sell reptiles have them.
Lucia: 各种各样吃的
Lucia: All sorts of food.
Lucia: 狼蛛吃的也很那个啥
Lucia: The wolf spider's diet is pretty intense.
Lucia: 他吃不过那个有的鸟也吃
Lucia: They can't out-eat some birds, though.
Lucia: 就那种小虫子
Lucia: They eat little bugs.
Lucia: 所以那个还比较好搞
Lucia: So it's kind of easy to manage.
Lucia: 面包虫
Lucia: Mealworms.
Lucia: 就是很多鸟也吃那个
Lucia: Lots of birds eat them too.
Jake: 我以为吃很多鸟
Jake: I thought they ate lots of birds.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice: 谁吃谁还不一定呢
Alice: Who eats who is still up for debate.
Alice: 哈
Alice: Ha.
Alice: 然后他的这个
Alice: And then his...
Alice: 这个跟他的腿中间有那个翼
Alice: Between his legs, he has these wings.
Alice: 然后就是可以从高处把它扔下来
Alice: So you can throw him from a height.
Alice: 他就像一个滑翔的效果
Alice: He kind of glides.
Alice: 对然后你就可以用比如说他从那里
Alice: Yeah, so you can, like, have him fly from there.
Jake: 蝙蝠的亲戚
Jake: Like a bat's relative.
Alice: 但是近亲吧
Alice: But more like a close cousin.
Alice: 他的表哥表弟
Alice: His cousins.
Jake: 那他最像的
Jake: The animal he resembles most is...
Jake: 我一般常见的动物是
Jake: The common animals I usually see are...
Jake: 行好好好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Alice: 然后比如说从那里飞过来
Alice: And, for example, he can fly over from there.
Alice: 哈哈哈从那里飞过来
Alice: Hahaha, fly over from there.
Alice: 然后你就接着他
Alice: And then you catch him.
Alice: 就他这种就特别粘人
Alice: He's very clingy.
Alice: 如果你接不住他他不会摔死
Alice: If you don't catch him, he won't die, but...
Alice: 但是他会被气死
Alice: He'll get really mad.
Alice: 就是你为什么接不住我呢
Alice: Like, why didn't you catch me?
Alice: 他真的会
Alice: He really would...
Alice: 他会气死
Alice: He would get mad.
Jake: 生气会干嘛就不吃饭
Jake: What happens when he's mad? He won't eat?
Alice: 反正会被会把自己气死啊
Alice: He'd just get so mad, he'd practically kill himself.
Jake: 就是不吃饭估计
Jake: Like, he would stop eating?
Lucia: 我好想养
Lucia: I really want to raise one.
Lucia: 我喜欢这种比较粘人的动物
Lucia: I love clingy animals.
Alice: 暹罗猫嘛
Alice: Like a Siamese cat?
Alice: 暹罗猫像狗一样的
Alice: Siamese cats are like dogs.
Jake: 它认识你
Jake: It knows you.
Jake: 会认识它认人
Jake: It recognizes people.
Alice: 它很粘人的
Alice: It's very clingy.
Jake: 蜘蛛应该没这样吧
Jake: Spiders shouldn't be like that, right?
Lucia: 蛇也不怎么认了
Lucia: Snakes don't really recognize people either.
Alice: 蛇不咬人就很粘人
Alice: As long as snakes don't bite, they're quite clingy.
Lucia: 但是但是我就是我爸妈不喜欢
Lucia: But, but my parents don't like them.
Lucia: 把家里弄得很乱
Lucia: They make a mess in the house.
Lucia: 所以我就不能养这种什么猫啊狗啊
Lucia: So I can't keep pets like cats or dogs.
Lucia: 这个散了
Lucia: It's a pity.
Lucia: 虽然我很想养
Lucia: Even though I really want to.
Alice:你在脑电波交流吗
Alice: Are you communicating via brainwaves?
Jake: 没有我看他这个灯关了
Jake: No, I just noticed his light was off.
Alice: 我灯还亮着呢
Alice: My light is still on though.
Jake: 但他其实是这个头发挡住了
Jake: But his hair was actually covering it.
Jake: 所以我刚刚让他撩一下
Jake: So I just asked him to move it aside.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahahahahahahaha!
Lucia: 你应该这样
Lucia: You should do it like this.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 就那天那个舞蹈里的动手
Lucia: Like that move in the dance the other day.
Alice: 所以昨天那个为什么
Alice: So why was it like that yesterday?
Alice: 那个什么161为什么代表3月21
Alice: Why does "161" represent March 21?
Lucia: 不知道可能是GPTS在胡说
Lucia: Maybe GPTS is just making stuff up.
Tasha: 不是没发昨天的工资
Tasha: Didn't they miss yesterday's payment?
Lucia: 好像是
Lucia: Seems like it.
Alice: 所以为什么
Alice: So why?
Alice: 为什么是321
Alice: Why is it 321?
Lucia: 他是睡着了
Lucia: He fell asleep.
Alice:161是吧 161为什么能代表3121
Alice: It's 161, right? How can 161 represent 3121?
Lucia: 不知道啊
Lucia: No idea.
Lucia: 我觉得GBT在胡说
Lucia: I think GBT is talking nonsense.
Lucia: 因为前一天的时候这个
Lucia: Because the day before, this...
Lucia: 他不是也拆成两个吗
Lucia: Didn't he split it into two as well?
Lucia: 然后经常也是的GPT
Lucia: And it was often the same with GPT.
Lucia: 里面有一个答案是说132是一个回纹数
Lucia: One answer inside said 132 is a palindrome.
Lucia: 但132明显不是回纹数
Lucia: But 132 is obviously not a palindrome.
Lucia: 就正着和倒着是一样
Lucia: It should be the same forward and backward.
Lucia: 就跟回纹是什么意思对吧
Lucia: That's what palindrome means, right?
Lucia: 132怎么是回纹数
Lucia: How is 132 a palindrome?
Lucia: 我在群里问我说为什么132是回文数
Lucia: I asked in the group why 132 is a palindrome.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 然后他说不知道所以没有采纳
Lucia: And then he said he didn't know, so it wasn't accepted.
Alice:是植树节
Alice: It's Arbor Day.
Alice: 植树节我还一开始我以为他弄错了
Alice: I thought he got it wrong at first for Arbor Day.
Alice: 他不是3月
Alice: Isn't it supposed to be in March?
Lucia: 是3月3月
Lucia: It is March, March.
Lucia: 3月十几号
Lucia: Around the middle of March.
Alice: 我我就记得我们不是312植树节吗
Alice: I remember our Arbor Day is on March 12th.
Lucia: 是吗我不知道但确实
Lucia: Really? I didn't know that, but yeah.
Alice: 是我记错了吗
Alice: Did I remember it wrong?
Alice: 我是但是那个日子
Alice: But that date...
Alice: 感觉就是跟我的印象好像
Alice: Doesn't match my memory.
Alice: 不太对啊
Alice: It feels off.
Alice: 然后我还去网上查了一下
Alice: So I looked it up online.
Alice: 原来每个国家的植树节都不是一样的
Alice: Turns out each country's Arbor Day is different.
Lucia: 原来是这样
Lucia: Oh, I see.
Lucia: 它不是个国际统一的节日
Lucia: It's not a globally unified holiday.
Lucia: 我的订单在京东
Lucia: My order on JD...
Lucia: 北京天河散货分拣中心
Lucia: It's at the Beijing Tianhe Distribution Center.
Lucia: 分拣完成
Lucia: It's sorted.
Lucia: 我觉得今天应该能到一个
Lucia: I think it should arrive today.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 别到时候我在淘宝上买那些小装饰
Lucia: Hope those little decorations I bought from Taobao arrive.
Lucia: 都没到然后那就会导致就是就是
Lucia: Otherwise, it'll be...
Lucia: 我所有到的东西都是白色的
Lucia: Everything I have will be white.
Alice: Lucia:
Alice: Lucia...
Alice: 白色是
Alice: White is...
Alice: 是水还是晶呢
Alice: Is it water or crystal?
Lucia: 因为我想弄成那种蓝
Lucia: Because I want it to be blue.
Lucia: 就是以蓝白为主色调的
Lucia: Mainly blue and white.
Lucia: 所以我挑的都是一些蓝白的东西
Lucia: So I picked blue and white items.
陌生人：简单打扫
Stranger: Simple cleaning.
Alice: 蓝白应该都属水吧
Alice: Blue and white should be water, right?
Alice: 好的谢谢您
Alice: Okay, thank you.
Alice: 啊阿姨
Alice: Oh, Auntie.
Alice: 那个底下那个黑色袋子里面是
Alice: There's broken glass in that black bag down there.
Alice: 是那个玻璃碎渣
Alice: Just in that black bag.
Alice: 就就这个黑色袋子
Alice: Yes, this one.
Alice: 对这个这个
Alice: Yes, yes.
Alice: 对对对里面是玻璃渣
Alice: There's broken glass in here.
Lucia: 小心一点
Lucia: Be careful.
Alice: 哎这里面是玻璃渣
Alice: Hey, there's broken glass in here.
Alice: 你小心
Alice: Be careful.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
陌生人：有垃圾要换吗
Stranger: Do you have any trash to exchange?
Tasha: 嗯没有
Tasha: Hmm, no.
Jake: 还有很多
Jake: There are still a lot.
Shure: 这确实会不一样
Shure: This will indeed be different.
Shure:  那你究竟哪种好
Shure: So which one is actually better?
Shure:  他肯定是是能对
Shure: He definitely is, right?
Jake: 但是这个优势就是这个
Jake: But this advantage is this.
Jake:这个优势
Jake: This advantage.
Jake:大哥先喝
Jake: Bro, you drink first.
Katrina:  还这种
Katrina: This kind too.
Katrina:  小花好呀
Katrina: How are you, Xiaohua?
Katrina:  大花就
Katrina: Dahuajiu...
Tasha: 法国服的话我还没有买
Tasha: I haven't bought any French clothes yet.
Tasha: 我们要不要看看
Tasha: Should we take a look?
Tasha: 还是什么服
Tasha: Or any other clothes?
Tasha: 嗯对怎么说呢
Tasha: Hmm, yeah, how should I put it...
Tasha: 好甜
Tasha: It's so sweet.
Tasha: 我在想每个人应该不太一样才行
Tasha: I think everyone should be a bit different.
Katrina: 哇可以有新衣服了
Katrina: Wow, we can have new clothes.
Tasha: 就那种粉黑色的
Tasha: Like those pink and black ones.
Katrina:  那他们男生跳舞
Katrina: So they dance?
Katrina: 可以可以
Katrina: Sure, sure.
Tasha: 然后你看有
Tasha: And look, there are...
Lucia: 男生跳舞跟我们一样的
Lucia: Boys dance just like us.
Tasha: 有你看这种的这种的
Tasha: Look at these, look at these.
Tasha: 这个粉哎这好好看
Tasha: This pink one, it's so pretty.
Katrina:  这好好看
Katrina: It's so pretty.
Tasha: 粉黑的这个
Tasha: The pink and black one.
Tasha: 对哎这好看
Tasha: Yes, it's pretty.
Tasha: 然后还有这个
Tasha: And then there's this one.
Tasha: 也可以来一个粉黑的
Tasha: You can also get a pink and black one.
Tasha: 然后这个也可以
Tasha: And this one too.
Tasha: 粉黑还真给爆了
Tasha: Pink and black really blew up.
Katrina:  真给爆了
Katrina: It really blew up.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Tasha: 我这就是这样一套
Tasha: That's just how this set is.
Tasha: 还有这套还带
Tasha: And this set also comes with.
Tasha: 也是粉黑的那种
Tasha: It's also pink and black.
Katrina:  嗯他给
Katrina: Hmm, he gave...
Tasha: 嗯他给多少预算
Tasha: Hmm, how much budget did he give?
Katrina:  多少预算
Katrina: How much budget?
Tasha: 我现在也是还可以吧
Tasha: I think it's still okay.
Tasha: 然后应该有三套了
Tasha: And there should be three sets.
Tasha: 我在想
Tasha: I'm thinking...
Tasha: 我找了好久才找到
Tasha: I looked for a long time before finding them.
Tasha: 找了好久
Tasha: Searched for a long time.
Tasha: 就是好多平台来回找才找着
Tasha: I had to go through so many platforms before finding them.
Katrina:  咱一共是一二三四个女生
Katrina: There are a total of one, two, three, four girls.
Tasha: 这边这边还有这个
Tasha: Here, here, and this one.
Tasha: 我们这个这个东西是这个
Tasha: We have this thing.
Tasha: 他可以修硕这个
Tasha: He can fix this.
Tasha: 这个一套两套
Tasha: This one, two sets.
Tasha: 一套两套还有这个
Tasha: One set, two sets, and this one.
Tasha: 嗯可以五套6套就可以了或者
Tasha: Hmm, five sets, six sets should be enough.
Tasha: 这一套
Tasha: This set.
Katrina:  嗯这一套也好看
Katrina: Hmm, this set looks good too.
Tasha: 嗯所以最后就是
Tasha: Hmm, so in the end...
Katrina:  你要不直接发群
Katrina: Why don't you just send it to the group?
Katrina:  然后大家挑
Katrina: And let everyone pick.
Tasha: 就是就6套吗
Tasha: So, six sets in total?
Tasha: 一共嗯
Tasha: Altogether, hmm.
Tasha: 然后就是我现在就一套200块他报不报
Tasha: So right now, it's 200 yuan per set. Will he cover it?
Katrina:  一套200块的话6套1200
Katrina: If it's 200 yuan per set, six sets is 1200 yuan.
Tasha: 嗯差不多1,000块钱左右
Tasha: Hmm, around 1000 yuan.
Tasha: 他会包吗
Tasha: Will he cover it?
Katrina:  你去问一下杨老板
Katrina: You should ask Jake.
Tasha: 然后如果想要的话
Tasha: And if we want it...
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 还得发顺丰才能周日到
Tasha: We need to use SF Express to get it by Sunday.
Tasha: 哦对
Tasha: Oh, right.
Katrina:  对确实对
Katrina: Yeah, that's true.
Tasha: 就是跳了好久才能找到一个一些
Tasha: I had to search for a long time to find a few.
Katrina:  行你先问他预算吧
Katrina: Okay, you ask him about the budget first.
Tasha: 谁去问哈哈哈
Tasha: Who's going to ask? Haha.
Tasha: 我们跳舞团团长去问一下
Tasha: Our dance team leader should go ask.
Katrina:  我靠我有点害怕
Katrina: Oh man, I'm a bit scared.
Tasha: 也有点害怕
Tasha: Yeah, I'm a bit scared too.
Tasha: 就是感觉有点太高了
Tasha: It feels a bit too high.
Tasha: 但是但是
Tasha: But, but...
Tasha: 每套都要很精致好看的话
Tasha: If every set has to be exquisite and nice...
Tasha: 一套150也不贵吧
Tasha: 150 for a set isn't too expensive, right?
Katrina:  那就在群里问吧
Katrina: Then let's ask in the group.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  说杨老板那个衣服给多少钱报销
Katrina: Ask Jake how much he will reimburse for the clothes.
Katrina:  哦那楼上没有牙膏了
Katrina: Oh, there's no toothpaste upstairs.
陌生人：啊
Stranger: Ah?
Katrina:  楼上没有牙膏
Katrina: No toothpaste upstairs.
Alice:阿姨你是来
Alice: Auntie, are you here to...
Katrina:  对没有牙膏
Katrina: Yes, no toothpaste.
Tasha: 怎么说谁去问一下
Tasha: So, who should go and ask?
Katrina:  在群里说一下
Katrina: Just mention it in the group.
Katrina:  就是现在找不到他人了
Katrina: We can't find him right now.
Katrina:  然后先在群里问一下
Katrina: So, just ask in the group first.
Tasha: 问问杨老板打歌服1000块行不行
Tasha: Ask Jake if 1000 for the performance outfit is okay.
Tasha: 服装
Tasha: The outfit.
Alice: 打歌服是吗
Alice: The performance outfit, right?
Katrina:  这是
Katrina: This is...
Katrina: 修硕们乐队的logo
Katrina: Shure's band logo.
Katrina: 送给大家穿着
Katrina: Gifting it for everyone to wear.
Alice: 这是鸟身上长了个柳树吗
Alice: Is this a bird with a willow tree on it?
Alice: 是吗
Alice: Is it?
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Alice: 你这看起来零零碎碎的
Alice: Yours looks all fragmented.
Alice: 不太好拼的样子
Alice: Seems hard to put together.
Shure:  吃饺子
Shure: Let's eat dumplings.
Jake: 哦谢谢
Jake: Oh, thanks.
陌生人：这些都不用动是吧
Stranger: These don't need to be moved, right?
Jake: 用不用了
Jake: Do they need to be moved?
Jake: 乌鸦你觉得要动吗
Jake: Nicous, do you think they should be moved?
Jake: 这些箱子可能还得用吧
Jake: We might still need these boxes.
陌生人：啊那你们留着吧
Stranger: Ah, then keep them.
Jake: 我们都留着
Jake: We'll keep them.
陌生人：我都留着吧
Stranger: I'll keep them.
Jake: 行我们都留着吧
Jake: Okay, we'll keep them.
Lucia: 也不用都我看一眼
Lucia: No need for all, let me take a look.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Sure.
Tasha: 不要那个泡沫箱能帮我拆一下吗
Tasha: Can you help me dismantle that foam box?
Lucia: 哪个这个
Lucia: Which one, this one?
Tasha: 哪个这里这个
Tasha: 对可以然后把那个蛋挞皮放到冰箱里
Tasha: Yes, that's fine. Then put the tart shells in the fridge.
Lucia: 这个这个这个泡沫箱
Lucia: This one, this foam box.
Tasha: 行冷冻这个这个这个喷火枪
Lucia: 哦这不是你的
Lucia: Oh, this isn't yours.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Tasha: 因为我怕他再不怎么弄他会不会化掉
Tasha: Because I'm afraid if he doesn't do it, it might melt.
Lucia: 行好OK稍等一下
Lucia: Okay, alright, just a moment.
Lucia: 我把这个地方收拾一下他一定没人
Lucia: I'll tidy up here, no one will be around.
Alice: 阿姨那个没人可以进去
Alice: Auntie, no one's in there, you can go in.
Jake:谢谢您
Jake: Thank you.
Lucia: 这些等一会大家拆再看吧
Lucia: Let's wait a bit before we open these.
Lucia: 他说粉色系和黑色系
Lucia: He said the pink set and the black set.
Jake: 我我瞅瞅去
Jake: I'll take a look.
Katrina:  哎他在这
Katrina: Hey, he's here.
Jake: 来瞅一瞅你们的衣服
Jake: Come and see your clothes.
Lucia: 我把这个一拆然后直接刚好让
Lucia: I'll open this up and then let it...
Jake: 我勒个去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Tasha: 这只是其中一套
Tasha: This is just one set.
Tasha: 这是第二套
Tasha: This is the second set.
Tasha: 这是第三套
Tasha: This is the third set.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 这怎么是一整个
Lucia: How is this a whole set?
Katrina:  就是哇哇哇
Katrina: I mean, wow, wow, wow.
Tasha: 是第四套第五套这是修硕的
Tasha: This is the fourth set, fifth set, this one is Shure's.
Tasha: 哈哈哈你看我帮他找了个男款
Tasha: 这是第6套
Tasha: This is the sixth set.
Tasha: 你觉哪套好看
Tasha: Which one do you think looks good?
Jake: 都好看
Jake: They all look good.
Jake: 想想啊
Jake: Let me think.
Lucia: 这是个完整的
Lucia: This one is complete.
Lucia: 这是啥情况
Lucia: What's going on?
Alice: 这吧我可以看一下这个吗
Alice: Can I take a look at this one?
Tasha: 眼神不好别多练
Tasha: Your eyesight is bad, don't practice too much.
Tasha: 哈哈哈眼神不好
Tasha: Hahaha, bad eyesight.
Katrina:  这个然后还有就是
Katrina: This one, and also...
Katrina:  那个可以弄在那个亚克力板里面
Katrina: That one can be put inside the acrylic board.
Katrina:  应该会挺好看
Katrina: It should look pretty good.
Katrina:  我想要不要压一点
Katrina: I'm thinking if I should press it a bit.
Katrina:  你要压吗
Katrina: Do you want to press it?
Katrina:  现在还有
Katrina: There's still some left now.
Katrina:  你可以把你那个盛开的就压一下
Katrina: You can press the one that's blooming.
Katrina:  随便弄两个就行
Katrina: Just do a couple, it's fine.
Katrina:  我这有有几个板
Katrina: I have a few boards here.
Tasha: 皮克皮克
Tasha: Peek peek.
Katrina:  其实特简单
Katrina: It's actually really simple.
Katrina:  就是把它一层层叠起来
Katrina: Just stack them layer by layer.
Katrina:  然后铺在上面
Katrina: Then spread it on top.
Katrina:  然后把它绑住就可以
Katrina: And then tie it up, that's it.
Alice: 它的原理是
Alice: The principle is...
Alice: 就是让这些容易吸水的材质
Alice: It's to let these absorbent materials...
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake: 这玩意有租的吗
Jake: Is this thing available for rent?
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Jake: 这玩意有租的吗
Jake: Is this thing available for rent?
Alice: 把它的水分吸干
Alice: ...to absorb its moisture.
Jake: 嗯这玩意有租的吗
Jake: Hmm, is this thing available for rent?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Huh?
Tasha: 租的
Tasha: For rent?
Tasha: 不知道哎
Tasha: I don't know.
Jake: 或者这玩意这玩意
Jake: Or this thing, this thing...
Jake: 哎或者这玩意能二手吗
Jake: Or can this thing be second-hand?
Tasha: 退吗
Tasha: Return it?
Jake: 或者这玩意能干掉吗
Jake: Or can this thing be dried out?
Tasha: 打歌服干掉什么意思
Tasha: What do you mean by drying out the stage clothes?
Jake: 就是就是省点钱
Jake: Just, you know, save some money.
Alice: 超预算了
Alice: Over budget.
Alice: 那要不统一买50块钱一套的
Alice: How about we just buy the 50-yuan set?
Jake: 不是就看你问问他
Jake: No, just ask them.
Jake: 你问问他
Jake: Ask them.
Jake: 便宜点或者你看能不能退掉
Jake: See if you can get a cheaper one or return it.
Jake: 二手还是能不能借租
Jake: Second-hand or rent it.
Alice: 或者搜一下附近有没有什么拍照的
Alice: Or search nearby for any photo studios.
Alice: 什么写真馆的
Alice: Like photo studios.
Alice: 他们那种礼服
Alice: They might have gowns.
Jake: 这种也行
Jake: That could work too.
Jake:100块钱我的蔬菜电脑再拿20块电脑
Jake: 100 yuan for my vegetable computer, and another 20 yuan for the computer.
Tasha: 或者这个就全部都买这一款
Tasha: Or we could just buy all of this model.
Tasha: 这一款才40块钱一套
Tasha: This one is only 40 bucks for a set.
Jake: 就看我们看看有没有别的渠道吧
Jake: Let's see if we can find other channels.
Jake: 就是除了买
Jake: I mean, other than buying.
Tasha: 可以 配黑裤子也可以
Tasha: You can pair it with black pants too.
Alice: 你可以配黑裤子也可以男生
Alice: You can pair it with black pants too, for guys.
Tasha: 男生
Tasha: For guys.
Jake: 对因为买的话好像没啥必要
Jake: Yeah, because buying it doesn't seem necessary.
Jake: 你问能不能退
Jake: Can you ask if it can be returned?
Jake: 或者就是或者就是他
Jake: Or maybe, or maybe he...
Jake: 他这个商家也没有什么租的
Jake: This seller doesn't offer rentals either.
Katrina:  没办法这个必须要做点手工活
Katrina: No way, we have to do some DIY.
Katrina:  我们要环保
Katrina: We need to be eco-friendly.
Jake: 你说我们就要6套吗
Jake: Are you saying we need 6 sets?
Jake: 你这是一家店啊
Jake: Is this one store?
Jake: 不同的店
Jake: Different stores.
Katrina:  我知道啊
Katrina: I know, right?
Katrina:  所以这个还算比较简单
Katrina: So this is quite simple.
Katrina:  他其实只要把花瓣铺上面
Katrina: He just needs to put the petals on it.
Katrina:  一定是哪个环节出了问题
Katrina: Something went wrong somewhere.
Katrina:  我看一下
Katrina: Let me check.
Alice: 为什么我觉得这个屋子比别的要热
Alice: Why do I feel this room is hotter than the others?
Alice: 是因为电脑多吗
Alice: Is it because of the computers?
Jake: 我觉得是
Jake: I think so.
Alice: 这个灯像一个苹果
Alice: This light looks like an apple.
Alice: 还有那个花边边
Alice: And that lace edge too.
Tasha: 哦还真的有租的
Tasha: Oh, there really are rentals.
Tasha: 他只能租这种
Tasha: He only rents this kind.
Jake:多少钱
Jake: How much is it?
Tasha: 45一套那为什么不买一套呢
Tasha: 45 per set, then why not just buy one?
Tasha: 买一套不到40吗
Tasha: A set is less than 40, right?
Jake: 确实租一
Jake: Indeed, renting one...
Jake: 这是什么
Jake: What is this?
Jake: 一件40租赁
Jake: 40 for a rental.
Tasha: 对啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake: 租多久
Jake: How long is the rental period?
Tasha: 租多久
Tasha: How long is the rental period?
Tasha: 不知道哎
Tasha: No idea.
Jake: 那这个是很厉害的服装吗
Jake: Is this some high-end clothing?
Jake: 这得1,000但是好像都是女的
Jake: It costs 1,000 but seems to be for women only.
Alice:但是这好像都是女的
Alice: But it seems to be for women only.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Tasha: 他这边且真话租租衣服的也比较多
Tasha: Over here, a lot of people actually rent clothes.
Tasha: 40块钱三三十块钱一
Tasha: It's 40 yuan, or 30 yuan per day.
Tasha: 一天
Tasha: Per day.
Alice:是一般多少钱一天
Alice: What's the usual price per day?
Jake: 一天30
Jake: It's 30 yuan per day.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Tasha: 那我要买一套40
Tasha: So if I want to buy a set, it's 40 yuan.
Tasha: 那就只能买最便宜的那个小卡了
Tasha: Then I can only buy the cheapest small card.
Jake: 就是不是那么重
Jake: It's not that heavy.
Katrina:  他的重心
Katrina: Its center of gravity.
Alice: 可以点歌吗
Alice: Can we request songs?
Shure: 可以
Shure: Yes.
Alice: 我想听蝴蝶
Alice: I'd like to hear "Butterfly."
Katrina:  蝴蝶我也想听蝴蝶
Katrina: I also want to hear "Butterfly."
Katrina:  再压一层
Katrina: Add another layer.
Jake: 蝴蝶你们挑
Jake: You choose "Butterfly."
Katrina:  那肯定是我还没有决定
Katrina: I haven't decided yet.
Katrina:  好陶喆
Katrina: How about David Tao?
Jake: 这是什么呀
Jake: What's that?
Jake: 桌子怎么长成这样
Jake: Why does the table look like this?
Lucia: 是桌子但是
Lucia: It's a table, but...
Lucia: 不是他拼起来是带抽屉的
Lucia: It's assembled with a drawer.
Alice: 这是一个不太小的工作量耶
Alice: That's quite a bit of work.
Katrina:  买那种香薰还有地毯还有挂画
Katrina: Buy those aromatherapy, carpets, and hanging pictures.
Katrina:  还有娃娃
Katrina: And dolls.
Lucia: 就是他带一个抽屉
Lucia: It comes with a drawer.
Lucia: 所以他会边上要这样立起来
Lucia: So it needs to stand up like this on the side.
Jake: 走吧吃饺子去
Jake: Let's go eat dumplings.
Katrina:  去二楼吃饺子吗
Katrina: Are we eating dumplings on the second floor?
Jake: 二楼吃饺子
Jake: Dumplings on the second floor.
Jake: 对冰箱也可以
Jake: Or the fridge is fine too.
Alice: 我们吃饭的时候需要录吗呃
Alice: Do we need to record while we eat?
Jake: 呃吃饭录着吧
Jake: Uh, let's record while eating.
Katrina:  这东西这怎么压呀
Katrina: How do we press this thing?
Katrina:  纯立体
Katrina: Purely three-dimensional.
Jake: 空心桌子是吧
Jake: A hollow table, right?
Katrina:  看收纳
Katrina: Look at the storage.
Lucia: 那最后是一个这样的一个小东西
Lucia: So in the end, it's this small thing.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 就有点像床头柜
Lucia: It looks a bit like a bedside table.
Alice: 让我看看
Alice: Let me see.
Jake: 嗯那这个就合理了起来
Jake: Hmm, that makes sense now.
Jake: 突然makesense
Jake: Suddenly, it makes sense.
Tasha: 培养皿买了吗
Tasha: Did you buy the petri dish?
Tasha: 在哪呢还不种
Tasha: Where is it? We need to plant now.
Tasha: 不种上不就来不及了
Tasha: If we don't plant now, it'll be too late.
Jake: 种
Jake: Let's plant.
Tasha: 什么时候种
Tasha: When are we planting?
Jake: 呃看他是不是看他到都没到
Jake: Uh, see if it's here or not.
Jake: 还有别的喝吗
Jake: Anything else to drink?
Katrina:  康乃馨
Katrina: Carnation.
Katrina:  这个这有个快递
Katrina: There's a package here.
Katrina:  是那个杨笑脸谁的
Katrina: Who is it for, Yang Smiley?
Jake: 笑脸
Jake: Smiley.
Katrina:  我给你我直接写的杨靖康
Katrina: I wrote it as Yang Jingkang.
Katrina:  那应该不是我买的
Katrina: It shouldn't be something I bought.
Katrina:  杨笑脸
Katrina: Yang Smiley.
Jake: 杨笑脸interesting
Jake: Yang Smiley, interesting.
Katrina:  是你买的吗
Katrina: Did you buy it?
Jake: 我不知道我看一下
Jake: I don't know. Let me check.
Tasha: 这什么
Tasha: What's this?
Jake: 这什么这什么呀
Jake: What's this? What is it?
Jake: 蝴蝶风铃
Jake: Butterfly wind chime.
Katrina: 我的
Katrina: It's mine.
Katrina:  哈哈哈给我看看啊
Katrina: Haha, let me see.
Katrina:  这是我材料包
Katrina: This is my materials kit.
Katrina:  今天又做手工了
Katrina: Doing crafts again today.
Katrina:  昨天化妆今天不想化妆
Katrina: Didn't put on makeup today after doing it yesterday.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina:  这我买的蝴蝶风铃
Katrina: I bought this butterfly wind chime.
Katrina:  你在追什么剧啊
Katrina: What show are you watching?
Jake: 这是货币是吧
Jake: This is currency, right?
Jake: 中央银行
Jake: Central Bank.
Katrina:  哈哈哈150个差不多吧
Katrina: Haha, about 150 should be enough.
Jake: 可以挺好大银行
Jake: That's good, a big bank.
Lucia: 哦我明白了这好像也不是那么难搞
Lucia: Oh, I get it. It doesn't seem that hard to handle.
Katrina:  呵呵AI学习中
Katrina: Haha, AI is learning.
Jake: 呵呵挺好
Jake: Haha, that's good.
Lucia: 我们才是AI是吧
Lucia: We are the AI, right?
Jake: 你这说明书对应的挺好呵呵呵
Jake: The instructions match quite well, hehe.
Tasha: 通州区演出服装租赁
Tasha: Costume rental in Tongzhou District.
Jake: 这个好甚至我们可以去挑啊
Jake: That's good, we can even go pick it out ourselves.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake: 如果不远的话
Jake: If it's not too far.
Jake: 我们
Jake: We...
Jake: 不远的话下午我们打个车去挑衣服
Jake: If it's not far, we can take a cab to pick out clothes in the afternoon.
Jake: 都可以
Jake: It's all good.
Tasha: 为什么不能打个车去买衣服哈哈哈
Tasha: Why can't we just take a cab to buy clothes, hahaha.
Tasha: 没关系我只是随便说说
Tasha: It's okay, I was just saying.
Jake: 到到时候算算
Jake: We'll calculate it then.
Jake: 算一算看看这打车费加上这多少钱
Jake: Calculate and see how much the cab fare adds up to.
Jake: 打车费应该到不了1,000
Lucia: 财务人员的一项工作
Lucia: Part of the accountant's job.